this is where the shootings started one
of two shisha bars to be targeted which
were known to be frequented by members
of the Kurdish community the 43 year old
perpetrator made his way into each place
and then opened fire indiscriminately on
innocent people
finally fleeing the scene in a car to go
home and kill his own mother before then
taking his own life the shock of the
local community is mirrored by that of
government ministers who confirmed their
primary line of inquiry everything is
being done to clarify up to the last
detail the background of these horrific
killings there are many indications at
the moment that the perpetrator acted on
right-wing extremist racist motives out
of hatred towards people of other
origins religion or appearance this is
not the first violent attack to be
associated with far-right criminals in
recent times a 27 year old man is
currently on trial for the murder of two
people outside a synagogue in the city
of Haller
last autumn
and last summer the Christian Democrat
mayor of a Western German city was shot
dead by a person with known links to the
far-right there's little doubt that
far-right violence is on the increase in
this country it's something many
mainstream politicians have been warning
about now some are wondering how many
more people must suffer before society
takes this threat seriously
Dominic Kane al jazeera Berlin